my father's Iranian he fled During the
Revolution and he was always big on
education he always said this to me
education is the only thing that no one
can tax you out of you can't lose in a
divorce the government can't take it
from you when I had the moment where I
was like I just lost everything I hadn't
lost the skills and the education that I
learned in that process that was the
thing that was valuable the First full
calendar year we did 26 million top
lines 17 million and take home and I had
been looking at bankruptcy lawyers 18
months earlier when you talk about like
what was the big clicking Point getting
my first gyms to start working I made
some money and then I went up into a
higher leverage business vehicle when we
did this it took off and then you
started a supplement line and that did
like 20 its first year